[Music]
also from our eight news now
investigators CCSD superintendent Dr
Jesus Jara was a passenger in a car
crash last month but left before Metro
Police arrived to investigate body cam
video showing the car Jar's assistant
was driving at the time no one was
seriously injured in the CCSD employee
was cited for following too closely
though Dr jar was in the car a
spokesperson says he left to go to
meetings there's no record of him in
Metro's crash report a Metro
spokesperson telling us at no point did
the traffic officer witness the presence
of the CCSD superintendent Jesus Shara
and no one on scene stated that he was
involved I have limited information it's
our superintendent that was involved in
the accident so we just got the
information from our Lieutenant that
9-1-1 call says otherwise CCSD saying in
a statement Dr Jara left after quote
everything appeared safe and authorities
were contacted no one other than the
CCSD employee was cited